okay so today we are doing Julius Caesar
and the fall of the Roman Republic um
Julius Caesar is considered the greatest
historical figure of all time he's also
one of the most controversial okay so
today um we're going to look at three
questions about his life and I want to
provide an argument uh about his life
okay so the first question we're going
to look at is um what did he want what
were his motivations for what he did did
did he want to become a king of Rome or
was he trying to save the Roman Republic
okay so this is a historical debate um
that's been around for us for about
2,000 years and no one has resolved it
second question I want to look at is why
was he so successful at what he did I
mean he he was a man who basically took
on the Roman Empire and he won okay so
how was he able to accomplish so much in
in only 55 years and the last question
is why did they kill
him because he was killed actually by
his friends by his allies by people he
grew up with by people he um fought Wars
with by people he pardoned and showed
mercy and generosity to okay so why did
they kill him all right
so my central argument
um to you today is that Julius Caesar
was so successful because he was a myth
maker okay A
mythmaker a mythmaker are individuals
who change the course of human history
because they they see themselves as a
Men of Destiny who must change the world
for the better and they do so by
constructing a new
reality that begins to absorb the old
reality and Alters it okay um and they
do do they do so through their um Words
Their speeches their writings and
through their
actions so they see themselves as the
main character the protagonist in a
novel that they are
writing all right so um this a hard
concept to understand but let's use some
examples to better understand this
concept so the first example let's look
at is the idea of Steve
Jobs Steve Jobs was an entrepreneur but
he was first and foremost of
mythmaker okay so Steve Jobs um if a
joke about Steve Jobs was Steve Jobs had
a secret weapon it was called a
reality
Distortion projector basically Steve
Jobs lied to people but he lied to
people people in such a
appealing manner in such a beautiful way
that it changed the
reality basically Steve Jobs imposed his
reality onto others and today that's why
we use Apple Computers right we all have
Apple Computers why do we do this
because we are participating in the myth
that Steve Jobs created for us right
that if you use Apple Computers you are
using the most advanced technology and
you are
uh participating in a um pleasing
lifestyle okay so it's it's about
technology but it's also about lifestyle
it's also about attitude and that's why
we are all using Apple computers today
because we are part trying to
participate in this myth
okay um another example is the idea of
movies right movies
are um reality creation machines when
you go see a movie it's a really good
movie it will stick in your mind and it
will change the way you perceive
reality okay so someone like Julius
Caesar what he was trying to do in his
life was create a new
narrative that would redefine
reality the last example I want to use
and I'm I'm really sorry for using this
example is Donald
Trump right because Donald Trump wants
to make America great again and and so
for his speeches and for his actions is
trying to construct or conceive a new
understanding of
America that absorbs the imagination of
everyone around him okay does that make
sense that's what a mythmaker
is and that's why ultimately julus
Julius Caesar was so
successful okay but the problem with
being a myth maker is by creating new
myths you are disrupting old myths that
people re rely on for their
understanding of the world okay you're
creating something called cognitive
dissonance and people don't like conon
dissonance it makes them
uncomfortable so they killed Julius
Caesar because his new myth of Rome was
surpassing the old myth of Rome and that
made the Old Guard uncomfort and that's
why they had to kill him all right so
that's my argument to you
today all right so now that I've made
the general argument let me provide some
historical background so we understand
the historical context that Julius
Caesar was operating in okay so let's go
back to
216 last class we talked about 216 BC
and this was the Hannibal
invasion of Rome and remember at the
Battle of canine Rome lost about 20% of
its um adult male population and at this
point Rome should have surrendered or
negotiated peace terms but Rome instead
chose to fought on and it fought on
because it had a mythology about itself
that was based on three principles right
the three principles are
piety uh
Liberty and
republ and because of these three
principles every
Roman felt it had to felt he or she had
to make the ultimate sacrifice in order
to save Rome okay and so everyone made a
sacrifice the
rich made
sacrifices by basically paying for the
war okay also the rich freed uh their
slaves so the slaves could become
citizens in order to fight for
Rome the poor also made a lot of
sacrifices
because um they have to fight fight in
the Army but also because the way the
Romans decided to defeat Hannibal and it
worked is something something we call a
scorched Earth
policy Scorch Earth policy basically
make the
land uh unfarmable so then you your army
has no access to food okay and that's
how they ultimately defeated Hannibal
because they burned all the land and
they couldn't grow food on the on the
land and so Hannibal's Army could not
feed itself okay so everyone made the
ultimate sacrifice the rich fought the
rich and the poor fought alike the rich
paid for the war the poor lost their
land okay and this is all possible
because of the nature of Rome at that
time n remember Rome at that time was
poor uh very small place where everyone
knew each other and ultimately uh it was
threaten with existence okay Hannibal
Hannibal proved to be an accidental
threat to Rome and that's why everyone
became uh
United um and made the timate sacrifice
okay and for Romans this was the finest
Hour this was the moment they celebrated
when there when the the very existence
was threatened by Hannibal but they came
together and made
sacrific and um ultimately defeated
Hannibal the problem was this the
problem was like after Rome won the
war the question then is who got the
rewards right everyone made the
sacrifice the poor lost their land the
rich lost their money and because the
rich
controlled uh the government remember
Rome is Republic it's not a democracy it
was decided the rich would get most of
the rewards of the war in fact the poor
got very little okay so an example here
is the idea of uh common land common
land is what do you do with the new
territory that you conquer in Spain and
from the caragan
Empire and
normally um common land would be given
to everyone right maybe in proportion
but it would be given to everyone
especially the poor who lost their
land but Rome made the
decision that the rich would be
compensated
for uh letting money to Republic during
the war meaning the rich got the lion
sheare of the new land but not only
that the the remaining common land the
rich just pretended pretended it was
theirs okay meaning that they illegally
occupied common land they didn't pay for
it it wasn't theirs but they just
assumed it was
theirs and
so now Rome had a problem Rome was great
when was poor and small and was
threatened by its neighbors like the
atrians the carthaginians and the Greeks
but by
BCE Rome had vanquished all its major
enemies and basically it was an Empire
and by 146 Rome had become a
contradiction okay the contradiction is
this it is an
imperial um
Republic okay it is an Empire now but
its former government is a
republic and this was a
contradiction and
suddenly these three values okay piety
Liberty and
Republica these values that made Rome
strong were now problems for the Roman
people okay so let me explain how let's
look at Republica repa means public
virtue in Latin it's the idea that the
best and brightest in Rome are in
competition with with each
other to promote the Roman National
welfare okay to bring glory to Rome
that's that's what if you were uh the
best in the brightest then your then
your responsibility to your family and
to the gods and to the nation was to win
new territory for Rome okay and so the
first thing you had to do was basically
uh win plal
office and
when Rome was poor it was basically a
meritocracy right you had to prove like
you were the best speaker or you had the
best resume in order to be promoted but
now that you have money what you realize
you could do is this bride people okay
and then so very soon bride we just
became a fact of politics in
Rome once you wanton plal office you can
then become a general to go off to
provinces to fight uh Wars to win new to
win new territory for Rome okay but
because you got into so much debt to win
the PO office when you went to the
province you did two things first of all
you exploited the local people okay
because you need to get back that money
that you uh spent the second thing that
you did was you start wars for no reason
okay you antagonize the locals in order
to start wars if you start wars you win
a lot of money right you can enslave the
people and make money that way but also
you will receive something call a
Triumph okay Triumph now Triumph is just
a military
parade that establishes you as a hero of
Rome and not only do you benefit
politically but your entire family
benefits okay so your sons your
grandsons your great-grandsons will all
be remembered and celebrated because of
your Triumph and they are much more
likely to um win plal office okay in
their careers okay so the Triumph is a
very very big thing the problem is while
the best and brightest were in
competition with each other the poor
were
suffering okay so the first problem is
land remember
during the annibal wars the Second Punic
War the poor lost a lot of land and they
were never compensated for it but then
what happened is as Rome was continuing
to fight these wars the poor was being
drafted into the
army and they were going to like Spain
and Syria these are far away places and
they were stuck there for like years
that meant their land couldn't be
cultivated and therefore they got into
debt
and they couldn't pay off the debt so
what happened was the rich would come in
and buy off the land at at very cheap
prices and so the rich became major land
owners and this is a problem because
first of all the poor didn't have any
land uh in order to grow food so they
were forced into the cities okay their
problem is the rich didn't want to grow
food to feed the people right they want
to grow food as cash crops for
export so suddenly for the first time in
its history Rome couldn't feed itself it
had to rely on imports from it's from
the
provinces okay so the land was a huge
issue but then you also had issues like
debt
right
so um the poor couldn't pay off uh their
debts and they became overwhelmed by the
uh by
interest and so this created lots of
problems for Rome okay so um you had a
lot of violence you have a lot of
corruption you have a lot of
inequality
okay and so this
started a
cycle um that Peter churon calls Elite
overproduction right so in s of peace
and as your population grows you're
going to have too many Elite who are now
competition with each other and it's
usually between the upper
nobility and the lower
nobility okay so upper nobility are
people who are established they're the
wealthiest citizens in all of Rome
they're very happy with the system as it
is the lower nobility are people who are
born into wealth but they want more they
want Prestige they want honor they want
the the Triumph and so they're
struggling against the upper nobility
for political power and usually you do
that by aligning yourself with the
people right and the people who now
numbering the millions are pissed off
because they have no land they're too
much in debt and no jobs okay and so
These two factions in Rome would be call
up noil would be call it
optimates okay optimates just means best
people we're the best and our
responsibility is to uphold to tradition
of Rome which is piety Liberty and
Republica okay and these people low
nobility who want to change they're
called populars and that's where we get
the term populace
from okay so in 146 BCE after Rome had
become an Empire and had defeated all
its enemies These two factions start to
emerge and they be and they clash with
each other okay so historians normally
believe the first Clash happened with
the graty brothers okay the Gras
brothers and these are again L nobility
who had a versible idea Land Reform okay
the idea is very simple you have rich
people who have too much land and not
using the land properly they're using
the land as parks for themselves like
these private parks for themselves or
they're going crash crop s which does
not feed R most of most most of this
land which is again common land the rich
are occupying it illegally is not being
used productively so what they proposed
was a simple Land Reform law okay and
the idea is this Rome the government of
Rome would buy out the rich from the
land they are illegally occupying okay
does that make
sense the rich won't be kicked off the
land they're illegally occupying they'll
be compensated for it okay so this makes
perfect sense not a problem right and
once Rome buys out this land it will
then give it redistribute it to the poor
so the poor will have like a social
safety system they able to feed
themselves and uh they'll usually
growing grain and other crops for
sustenance and this will enable the
feeding of the Roman population in
general okay so this sounds very simple
to us but the rich didn't like this idea
because they like change in general okay
they like the idea of pety Liberty and
Republica which means things must stay
this must stay the way they are and
what's really important is the rich
cannot be challenged by the poor because
if that were the case then the social
system would be overhauled okay so the
rich were so pissed off that they
assassinated both brothers the grai
brothers and most orians believe this is
the beginning of the fall of the Roman
Republic because it tells us that the
system is
incapable of
change
okay the system as is set set up which
focus on pety Liberty and Republic uh
it's a contradiction now and this
contradiction cannot be internally
resolved all right so any any more
questions any questions before I proceed
on from I I I I no this a lot and maybe
I haven't organized it properly but uh
do are there any confusions about this
history so far again I'm I'm just
provide some background and context
before I move on to Julius
Caesar
yeah okay yeah this is a great question
okay what what's the relationship
between optimates and the popular
leaders okay there's exactly like 20
noble
families in Rome okay and so the these
people the optim and populars all come
from these 20 noble families and they're
like cousins of each other okay so The
Optimist are maybe like the fathers and
the grandfathers and the popularist are
like the sons does that make sense right
because um the fathers don't want any
change but the sons want political
power and and so they're all related
they all grw with each other they all
know each other
okay does that make sense okay all right
um EO are are you good is this clear to
you so far all right all right so the
first major conflict is the gry brothers
second major conflict that happens or
something called a um social
war and the social war is basically this
the people who fight the wars are the
Allies the Italian allies of Rome okay
people who live in the neighboring um
provinces they're the ones who fight the
war and after Rome keeps on winning
these
wars um Rome refuses to Grant
citizenship to them okay so these U
neighbors Rebel and there's a civil war
going on in Rome and Rome loses this war
and Rome grants has is forced to Grant
citizenship
to um these neighbors but the question
then is what is the nature of
citizenship like how much rights do you
get how much power do you get because uh
Roman is a republic and so one thing
that's hard for us to understand is not
all voters are equal okay so if you're a
rich voter you have more power than if
you are a poor voter okay so the
question then is these new citizens of
Rome what sort of V voting rights will
they have and this is a issue that that
that became a huge issue over the next
few decades okay so the social war then
you have these slave revolts these what
what what they call the surval
wars
okay uh then you have these piracy going
on so Rome the woman Republic is
constantly in tormo and in
Conflict okay and the war between the
optimists and the populars becomes so
intense that ultimately they fight a
civil war okay a Civil War means two
armies killing each
other okay and so the Civil War was
between
solah and uh
Marius and the Civil War BEC so intense
that both solah and Marius do the
unthinkable and they marched their
armies into Rome and kill their enemies
this is never been done in Roman history
before as a general you're not supposed
to take your soldiers and March against
your own government against your own
City and kill your own people okay but
that's what they both do um Sola wins
the Civil War and he understands like
all
Romans
that this can't go on okay there has to
be a solution and solar solution is well
you know if the problem is a conflict
between the populars and after mits
let's just kill all the populars and
then the problem will be solved then you
have stability in Rome okay and this is
what we refer to as prescription
prescription and prescription means this
there's a list public a public list of
about a thousand 2,000 okay
individuals and these individuals are
basically sanctioned to be killed so if
you go kill them not you'll be rewarded
by the state and you'll be given the
property of those you
killed okay and it's it's called
prescription and this is a new invention
by Solo in order to resolve the conflict
between the optimates and the
populars one of those
individuals who was designated to be
prescribed his name is Julius Caesar and
he's about 19 years old now okay and
Julius Caesar comes from a very
prestigious uh Roman family called the
julii and he's the nephew of
Marius and that's why he was he was
prescribed
okay now the good thing is if you're
rich you can bribe your way out of these
things okay and Julius julus Caesar's
family was extremely wealthy and um uh
he was able to bribe solola into let him
go okay so Julius Caesar's life was
Spear and Sola believed that by doing
this uh by killing off the populars by
making the optimates the supreme power
in the land this conflict would go
away but after solah died this didn't
happen Okay in fact the conflict became
even
worse okay so Julius
Caesar grew up in this
conflict right he grew up in a time of
the imperal Republic a contradiction and
he saw himself as a man of Destiny to
save the Republic by implementing
reforms necessary in order
to um restore stability in Rome okay he
basically wanted to make Rome great
again any questions so
far is this all clear to you
guys
okay all right so um
let's talk about the life of Julius
Caesar okay from an early age Julius
Caesar saw himself as special but not
only that but from an early age Julius
Caesar cared a lot about his Public
Image he cared about how people
perceived and remember him okay so uh
here here's a story to highlight The
mythmaking Genius of Julius Caesar okay
so when you was 25 he was sent off to um
Anatolia to work as an official there
now the problem with sailing at this
time is there's a lot of piracy right
because there's a lot of corruption
inequality and poverty in in the Empire
and so in 25 Julius Caesar was kidnapped
captured and kidnapped by Pirates not a
big deal because he's of the nobility
and it's obvious he's of the nobility
and so Pirates asked for a ransom his
paid the ransom and Julius Caesar was
free to go okay now very simple story
but what julus Caesar did was he embell
a story okay he made certain adjustments
to the story that made it memorable to
people so that people would discuss it
everywhere okay the first embellishment
he made was
this the Pirates asked for a 20 silver
Talent Ransom okay which is a lot of
money and Julius Caesar said when I
heard this I felt insulted how dare you
ask for 20 Civ talents I'm worth at
least
50 okay so hey guys don't ask for 20 ask
for 50 my family can afford it okay so
that's the first embellishment the
second embellishment he made
was Julie Cesar said I became friends
with the Pirates we drank together he
he's a very charismatic
individual um and I told them while we
were drinking hey guys after I go home
I'm going to come back and like capture
all of you and crucify every one of you
the fire's like that's really funny man
okay so that's second embellishment the
third embellishment is julus Julius
Caesar after was he was released he set
up a navy and he went and found every
one of these Pirates and crucified every
one of them okay and that's a third
embellishment because we actually don't
know if he actually did this but again
the thing that Julia Caesar understands
is it doesn't matter if the facts are
true or not what matters is how
appealing are the details right so this
story you will remember forever and you
will tell others about it so through
this he's creating a myth of himself
okay does that make
sense and again there's no way any of
these things are true right he's like oh
20 talents I'm insulted ask for 50 guys
okay and while he's drinking with these
guys and these are pirates these are
like Psychopaths right he's like I'm
gonna come back and kill every one of
you every one of
you but again that's a mythmaking genius
of Julius Caesar
so
um again as a Young Man the greatest
honor in Rome is to achieve the Triumph
and you do that by starting Wars so um
through bribery and through Charisma
Caesar is elected a pror and then as a
pror he goes off to Spain he fights
these wars against the tribes of Spain
uh and then he wins a Triumph
okay and what he wants to do is he wants
to basically use a Triumph as the
springboard for his for his political
career to win the council
ship at this point okay okay the
optimists hate Julius Caesar because
Julius Caesar again he's a mythmaking
genius he's telling all these stories
and it's pissing off the optimists
because they see Julius Caesar as you
know as he's just a bragged okay he's
arrogant he he just brags all the time
he's um appeasing the people he's he's
exactly what Romans should not be okay
okay he's ire he doesn't care Liberty he
doesn't care about the public good all
he cares about his own personal glory
and he's got a reputation for this he's
also got a reputation for being a Leber
uh libertin okay meaning like he sleeps
with man and woman everywhere okay and
the Roman optimates okay people who
include KO cpio and Cicero okay these
are the three most famous they hate
Julius Caesar with a passion they think
Caesar represents all that's wrong with
Rome here's a young man who has talent
and
Charisma and he's a genius of some sort
but he's using it not for the glory of
Rome but for his own personal political
advancement Caesar represents to them
the corruption of the Roman Republic
okay and they develop you you can use
this phrase Caesar derangement syndrome
okay they have this decided that they
will do whatever they can to destroy
this
guy so Caesar wins a tri and he wants
the win the wins and he wants to get the
counselor ship okay the problem is you
can only be a general to get the
Triumph but you have to give up your
generalship in order to stand for
election for the council okay so the
optimates give him a choice you can
either have the Triumph or you can have
the counsel ship it's your choice and
they think this guy he's so arrogant he
will never give up the
Triumph okay and Cesar surprises
Everyone by giving up the Triumph he's
like I don't want this crap I want to
stand for
election all
right so that's the other thing that's
really surprising about you
Caesar he's unpredictable okay or you
can also argue he UND understands the
mentality or the motivations of his
opponents but his opponents do never
understand him okay they always
underestimate
him okay so Caesar is councel and as
councel he wants to do what everyone
wants to do and promote stability in
Rome okay so he's promoting Land Reform
and here
the uh optimat try to obstruct him
wherever they can okay the other thing
is is after the council ship Caesar
wants to go take over Gaul okay and Gaul
is a northern province in Rome and there
he wants to win glory for
himself okay that's a plan the authors
understand this and so beforehand they
decide the next Council will be sent to
Italy okay which is like basically Rome
if you're in Rome you can't fight Wars
you can't fight Wars you can't win Glory
you can't have Triumph okay and that's
the idea we'll let cesure be counil but
we'll have him in Italy uh building
roads and cutting wood and and cutting
trees okay we're not going to let him go
fight Wars and go that's for sure Caesar
knows about this and he does something
that's really unexpected he forms an
alliance with two other individuals that
the Senate hates okay the first is
Pompei and Pompei is considered uh the
greatest general of Rome he's called
pompe The Great and uh he's also pissed
off the Senate because pomp the great
wins all these wars for Rome and he has
to um settle his veterans right he has
to give L to his veterans but the Senate
refuses okay so pomp is pissed off at
the Senate as well and then there's
Cris and Cris is the richest man in Rome
he's the wealthiest man in Rome and he's
pissed off at the Senate as well because
is blocking a lot of his political
career okay so they form a secret
alliance called the first Triumph rate
and so they do a lot of these deals okay
so Caesar as Council will help settle uh
the the veterans of Pompei they'll Pro
promote some tax reform that Cris wants
and in return Pompei and Gris will give
him
go as the problems that he will take
over once he's he leaves his coun okay
so that's a
plan when go when Caesar becomes coun uh
leader of Gul the provincial governor of
Gul okay the the pro counil from 58 to
BC at this point cesure becomes a legend
in Rome okay this is where his
mythmaking genius really
shines he goes and commits genocide in
goal basically okay okay in the words of
Caesar I went to go I killed a million
Gos in War I enslaved a million
gos and then I let a million gos live
okay so he basically committed genocide
against the GS and it was all for his
personal glory and he starting all these
wars in go uh in order to accomplish
three things okay the first thing he
wanted to do uh was money okay he got
into a lot of debt uh because he had to
bribe a lot of people in order to secure
his counsil ship and he has to pay them
off right so he made a lot of money the
money that he had left over he sent back
to Rome to organize
feasts and festivals for the Roman
people okay the term we use today is
called bread and
circus bread and circus okay so so
that's uh what Caesar was doing in in
order to Eng gratiate himself with the
Roman people okay so that's the first
major purpose of these wars second major
purpose of these wars is to create the
world's greatest army remember Rome is
mainly at peace at this time and if
they're fighting Wars they're fighting
Wars against a lesser opponent okay the
gos are tough
Warriors um and the Roman his Roman
soldiers are getting the best training
in the world through eight years of
constant fighting the goals okay so
through this process he created the most
loyal and the most disciplined army in
the world and they all and it they're
all loyal to him personally okay because
he's the one rewarding them and he's the
one um who brings Victory to them right
the second thing the third thing which
is the most important
is he creates the myth of Caesar as the
great conqueror okay Romans love
generosity Romans love conquerors and
while Caesar was in go fighting these
wars what he would do is he would write
down dispatches or maybe reports right
then he would send his a soldier back to
Rome and in the form of Rome okay the
main uh Place public place he would
stand up and he would read the
composition of Caesar of that week and
the things he was doing was I mean it
basically captured the imagination of
Rome of all Romans okay so for example
he attacked
Germania Germania um and Romans fought
the Germans were so barbaric it was
impossible to attack them the second
thing that that um Caesar did to capture
the imagination of Romans is he invaded
Britain Britain in
imagination uh of Romans was this
mystical uh imaginary
place and no one knew what it was and
and Caesar launched two major
Expeditions against Britain that didn't
really do anything but that was the
point the point was Caesar ventured into
the unknown okay it's basically
equivalent back then of the moon landing
does that make sense because it was just
unheard of like why would you go to
Britain aren't there like dragons in
Britain aren't there like sea monsters
in in in in Britain and Cesar went and
uh went there twice okay so at this
point the Romans worship Caesar okay
Caesar bribing them with like in Circus
uh and he's winning all these military
exploits in Gul and
he's um constructing a new reality of
Caesar as the great
conqueror
okay so does does it make sense so far
okay he's a myth
maker so while Caesar is doing this the
optimists uh in Rome back in Rome Kato
cpio and ciso they now see what a
threat Caesar is they realize this guy's
not beatable if he runs for elections
he's going to win all the elections his
allies are going to win the elections so
this they decide to strip him of his
command of his military command and put
him on trial for all the things he did
illegally okay and Caesar he's not a
nice
person he's done a lot of illegal uh
immoral things in order to accomplish
power right so the Senate has a major
case against him and at this
point um Caesar recognizes that listen
these guys mean War so what cure does is
he basically declares war on Rome he
cross the Ruban
okay um and the Senate uh is appalled by
this and they appoint Pompei who again
is considered the greatest General in uh
Rome at this point at at this point to
counter Caesar okay and this
starts the second Civil War the first
civil Civil War was between Sol and
maras okay so now it's Caesar versus
Pompei any questions so far about
this
sure oh that that's a great question
okay so the Senate um is about um it's
about 300400 people it's a lot of people
okay but the power in the Senate is not
distributed
equally so if you are so think of the
Senate as maybe many circles okay if you
are the main if you have the most power
you sit at the front why is that
important because you're able to speak
if you sit at the
front does that make sense so even
though technically voting everyone has
the same voting rights the people at the
front are those who are able to set the
agenda and control the debate and make
speeches everyone back here are not
allowed to say anything okay because you
go in CHS the people who sit up the
front are the optimists because they
come from the most prestigious families
and they have the most uh illustrious
political careers okay does that make
sense all right so when Caesar uh
invades Rome basically SP declared war
on the Roman senate okay so let's look
at a map of Rome at this time this is
the year 49 BC all right so Rome is an
Empire you have Italy here this is
Rome uh over
here um
is um basically Northern Africa over
here is
Spain over here is um
Greece over here is
Anatolia uh
Syria okay so that's the Roman Empire
okay
at this point
when
um Caesar cross Ron he's able he's he
controls basically Gul which is poor
which is poor okay he controls
Rome the um timates and Pompei they
control Spain uh Greece Anatolia Syria
and Northern Africa there a problem for
Caesar because
remember Rome gets its food from the
provinces okay so in other words all
pumpy has to do is weight this is what
what we call a containment strategy
containment
strategy look Cesar can't do anything
right and eventually because Romans are
starving because of this blockade then
the Romans will rise against Caesar game
over okay that's all the Au have to do
just wait it out
over time Caesar will lose the Loyalty
of his troops and of the Roman people
and then he will have and then he will
be weak and then then and then at that
point they're going to attack him okay
the war will be over does that make
sense all right so the odds are against
Caesar because is basically one man
versus an entire
Empire okay but cure has two advantages
he has two major advantages the First
Advantage he has
is he has again the world's greatest
military who has who have fought eight
years in Spain they're extremely
disciplined they're extremely devoted to
him okay that's the first major
advantage the second major advantage is
the division within the timate
opposition okay because even though the
alats KO and cro and cpio they don't
really they hate Caesar
they don't trust Pompei either right
because as this war continues more and
more power will Ur to Pompei right he's
going to have more and more power so
even though pompe wants to drag this war
out the timates don't want this war to
drag out they're afraid that by giv of
Caesar as dictator they will make Pompei
the
dictator because the what they want to
do is like maintain the status quo right
they don't want a new king to arise they
don't they don't want a situation where
Caesar loses but pompe wins okay does
that make sense so Ops are pushing
Pompei to end the war as quickly as
possible all right and this division
will be costly in fact it will basically
cost pompei's
life so given these two advantages the
Visions within the optimate um
opposition and given that Caesar has the
world to his army Caesar decides he must
take the offensive okay so first thing
he does is he takes his army to Spain
and crushes all opposition in Spain when
he crushes opposition in Spain he does
something that's not very Roman okay he
offers
clemency
to the
enemy basically tells his enemies okay
um we're all Romans we're all fighting
for the greater good of Rome so I've won
this war will you promise not to fight
against
me if you promise you won't fight
against me anymore I'll let you go okay
and when he did that some chose to just
go home but there are also many who like
who chose to go and fight for Pompei in
Greece okay all right but that's what
Trump what what what Julius C is doing
he's winning these wars against his
opponents and he's letting them go he's
forgiving them so that's the first thing
that Caesar does and then he marches to
Greece and again at this point pom
doesn't have to do anything and pom
doesn't want to do anything because he
knows that cesure has a superior Army
okay these are two of the greatest
generals Rome has ever produced okay
Caesar and Pompei they understand each
other they understand Warfare and Pompei
just wants to use the contain
containment strategy and starve Caesar
out
Caesar wants to fight a
battle right away okay and what tips a
balance is the optimat who Force sorry
uh the optimat KO CIO and cro who Force
Pompei to fight a battle and in um
August 48
BC at a place called farcus the two
armies meet okay Pompei and
Caesar Pompei chooses to use the Anvil
and and Hammer
strategy remember what the eval and
Hammer strategy is where your infantry
locks the enemy enemy enemy Army into
place okay it locks in place and then
from behind the Cavalry comes in and
wipes out the enemy infantry okay that's
a strategy this is what Alexander the
Great uh this is the strategy that
Philip and Alexander the Great used
against uh the Greeks and Persia
okay the problem
is the
uh uh Jud Cesar's Army is so disciplined
and so experienced that they with the
calvalry
charge and they weped out the Army at
farcus
okay then Caesar took his army to uh
Egypt conquer that to Syria conquer that
and to Anan conquer that okay the Senate
asked for a report from Caesar like
House of work going what's happening
okay and
Caesar said the most famous line that he
ever said and again he's mythmaking
genius right he basically said uh
Vin V vich okay beautiful Latin the most
powerful Latin phrase ever spoken in
human history it
means I came I saw I
conquered okay and again this captur the
imagination of the the Roman people
after
Caesar calmed the Roman East he goes to
Africa to fight uh Kato and cpio at the
Battle of FIS
okay and again Cesar wants to show
clemency he wants to show how generous
and merciful he is but at this point his
soldiers who are getting very old they
want they they just want they just want
this war to end and they want to go home
so at this battle what they do is did
they
defy the orders direct orders of Caesar
not to
engage they took it upon themselves to
attack the enemy and at this point the
winning of the war right the winning of
the battle Caesar orders them to show
Mercy the veterans his veterans Massacre
their enemies to ensure they can't fight
back again okay
the last battle is in Spain at the above
Manda and
here uh the enemy is on a hill and
you're not supposed to fight uphill okay
you're not supposed to go up a hill and
fight the enemy there because you're at
a major disadvantage
right seizure soldiers now are so
experienced and disciplined that they
can do that they can just March up the
hill and and destroy the enemy okay so
that's how powerful Caesar's enemy uh
sorry that's how powerful Caesar's Army
is at this point the they basically wipe
out every army they fight against they
reconquer the Roman
Empire does that make sense Cesar goes
back to
Rome uh in
44 um and this is the year he will be
assassinated by his
friends he
launches legislative reform to reform
the Roman Republic okay he launches Land
Reform he launches debt
relief he creates something called the
Julian
calendar the Julian calendar is what we
still use today before Julius Caesar the
Romans used the lunar calendar and then
and then Julius Caesar working with
astronomers they designed together the
Julian calendar which is exactly what we
still use today okay that's a major
reform um he offered clemency
to all his enemies basically if you're
willing to work for the good of Rome he
will invite you back into the
Senate okay he offer
citizenship to his soldiers and to
um uh Italians okay he he brought in
citizenship in Rome so what Cesar was
doing was he was basically trying to
resolve a lot of the contradictions that
led to instability and civil war and
revolution in Rome before then
okay and he was
successful and he
was um considered a genius he was led by
the people in fact he was everywhere um
he had bust of himself everywhere okay
and he and then he made he made he
mitted coins money that has that has f
on it so he's basically creating what we
call a cult of
personality
okay
and he wanted to continue to expand the
Roman Empire um his plan was to go fight
uh a place called Parthia which is the
old Persian Empire and then he wanted to
go conquer Germania okay he basic wanted
to conquer the entire world
that was his ambition his ambition was
to make Rome uh great again and he
almost succeeded except ultimately he
was killed by his friends he was
assassinated in 44 uh BC
okay so
um let's look at those three questions
again okay first of all what motivates
Caesar second question is why did he
succeed the third question is why did
they kill him okay okay so I think what
motivated him is exactly what motivated
uh someone like Sola and Marius and
other great generals of Rome they want
to make Rome great again they're
nostalgic for the Rome uh of the
Hannibal Wars right when everyone came
together uh and made the sacrifice
necessary in order to protect and save
Rome he wanted to return that
era okay and I that's what motivated him
he didn't want to become king um and if
he became king he didn't want to stay as
king remember Sola won the war and he
could have made made himself King but he
didn't do that he implemented a lot of
reforms and then he retired because that
was the Roman way okay that's what the
ancestors did and he wanted to be loyal
to the gods to the ancestors and to Rome
okay so Cesar didn't want to become king
he just wanted to save uh role second
question then is how is he able to
succeed and this is a more difficult
question okay so again the argument is
he's a mythmaker what does that mean
okay so there are different individuals
in
society that uh promote the social good
okay or they're they're able to
accomplish great things in different
aspects of society the first is a
general right the general
the general he is bold and disciplined
and he's fear right that's why the
soldiers follow him he's bold he's
disciplined and he's Fair he's also
concerned about um
organization and Logistics how do you
move an army from place to place how do
you feed your
army okay that's that's what the general
does that's that's what a great General
does that's what Hannibal did okay
then you have the politician and the
politician he's basically like an
avatar of the people he's able to
capture and represent the emotions and
the dreams and the longings of the
people okay he's very
charismatic and he's very manipulative
okay he's able to tell stories that
capture the emotional
imagination of the people that's what
the the politician does then you have
the
administrator or the legislator okay and
this person is very concerned about
details and law and legal aspects okay
regulation and very and the person you
can say is almost a systems design
thinker very big picture very macro and
trying to figure out how the different
pieces fit together if you think about
it these three individ uals the general
the politician and and the administrator
the legislator they're very different
personalities they're in contradictions
with with each other okay so for example
Pompei was a great General but he's a
terrible terrible
politician okay Hannibal was a uh great
General too but he was not a very good
um legislator
okay the thing that made Julius
Caesar
distinctive is he was all
three together okay because what enables
you to be all three together is the
imagination that was julius's secret
power his imagination he was able to
imagine himself as different people at
once and therefore he was different
people at once he had multiple
personalities
and that's why he was so unpredictable
that's why he was able to understand the
motivations of his
opponents and that's why he was able to
accomplish so much
okay does that make sense okay and so he
so he became a
mythmaker the problem with being a
mythmaker is you ultimately have to
change
reality and by changing reality you make
people who are accustomed to reality
uncomfortable
okay and so that's why he was killed he
was killed by not by not his enemies but
by his friends okay so there were four
major conspirators against Julius Caesar
they were Decimus
Buddhist who is basically uh who was
basically Caesar's lieutenant in war you
had tonius again another major
Lieutenant of Caesar but you also had
casassus and casassus was actually
fighting for Pompei but Caesar thought
he was such a great General that Caesar
pardoned him okay and you also had uh
Marcus
Brutus who Caesar actually saw as a
son okay so these are the people who are
closest to Caesar and they ultimately
killed Caesar because even though Caesar
was making Rome better it was changing
Rome which caused them to feel
uncomfortable and anxious about the
future of Rome okay does that make sense
so an analogy is this let's just say
that one day the Chinese government says
we're gon to Outlaw rice right white
white rice because right rice has proven
to be
scientifically uh bad for you okay it's
not nutritious for you instead we're
going to make every Chinese eat steak
and potatoes and broccoli so that
Chinese can be strong and healthy okay
how do Chinese feel about this they'd be
pissed okay you understand so you know
it's unfortunate that Caesar did nothing
wrong and what everything everything
that Caesar did was for the good of
Rome but change reform causes conif dis
okay it makes people anxious and
uncomfortable okay it disrupts your
identity
and um that's why there's conspiracy
that ultimately killed Caesar
okay does that make
sense
okay okay
um okay so the question how did Caesar
challenge the identity of being Roman
okay that's a great question all right
so let's let's look at his reforms first
of all he had a Julian calendar right
the Julian calendar so he was
challenging people sense of time time
you understand so before you had the
lunar calendar now now you have the
Julian
calendar second thing that he did was he
was doing all all this stuff by himself
okay he was winning these military
victories by himself he was uh
introducing uh much un reform
legislation by himself he was a great
man but if you're
Roman what you have been taught is these
three ideas pety piety Liberty and
Republic which is say no one is above
Rome everyone is equal in the eyes of
Rome this General
who won
against um Hannibal or Carthage or the
Greeks it wasn't because he was a great
man it was
because he was fighting for Rome
okay so the fact that Judi Caesar was
his
genius that he was so brilliant and he
was able to accomplish so much it made
them jealous right it made people
jealous but at the same time it made
them uh um it made it made them see him
as a threat to the very stability of
Rome does that make sense because people
like jul Caesar aren't supposed to
exist there Rome does not need Kings in
fact Rome is anti-
monarchy okay so they they were much
very much afraid that Julius
Caesar um found himself as a God and he
would make himself King and in fact uh
Julius Caesar I mean had huis
right obviously if you believe that you
by yourself can change Rome you have
huous but he was not showing enough
deference to the Senate he was creating
a c of Personality he was being very
arrogant it seemed very much like he
want to become king okay does that make
sense okay so there's a lot of evidence
to suggest that cure wanted to become
king that's why made them uncomfortable
okay what I'm saying is
uh the real issue is the idea of con
dissonance where the very existence of
Caesar challenge their perception of
what Rome was and what Rome
meant does that make sense but very good
question okay any more
questions crashes
oh okay so um Pompei and Crashers and
seizure how did they um um how did they
form their lines right okay so the first
thing to understand is pumping cres were
both
optimists okay they were supporters of
Sola remember Sola is the one who
crushed the populars right so pompe and
cres were were conservatives they were
optimists Caesar was a
popular so um their Alliance was secret
it was completely unexpected and that's
that's why they were able to accomplish
so much because politically they were at
odds with each other the reason why they
formed Alliance is just basically
expedience Pompei had issues that he
wanted to pass through the senate cres
had issues that he wanted to pass
through the Senate and Caesar as well so
they decided it would be politically
expedient to work together that's a
genius of Caesar okay he's very chmatic
he's very manipulative so he was able to
um form alliance with people who were
technically his enemies okay pompe and
crashes were his enemies they were they
were politically at odds with him but
Caesar was able to put aside uh
political differences and form an
alliance for the sake of interest and
expediency okay does that make sense
but obviously this would not last very
long okay any more
questions
okay okay so next
class we're going to look at the world
that Cesar created okay because after he
dies um the Republic
Falls so we will look at what happens
after he dies dies and look at the birth
of the Roman Empire okay